[Music]
Dr. Wallik is going to explain to you
tonight not only about cardiac myopathy
but many other things. I pray that you
listen closely and carefully because
what you're going to hear may save your
life or the life of your loved one. Dr.
Wallik in 1991 was nominated for the
Nobel Prize. He's had many, many
fabulous things in his life.
There's no way I can tell you how
pleased I am to have him here in Kansas
City tonight. And I want to turn the
time over now to Dr. Joel Wallik. Would
you all give him a big hand?
How many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock? Well, I tell you what,
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West St. Louis County
back in the 50s.
And we start out with beef calves and uh
if if you raise livestock, the only way
you can make money is if you raise a lot
of your own feed for those of you who
don't have that experience. And so we
raised our own corn and we raise our own
soybeans and our own hay. And we had a
truck come out from the mill. And this
truck would come out from the mill and
it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay. And then we would
add sacks of vitamins, minerals, trace
minerals, and we'd make pellets out of
it. And this is what we would feed the
calves. In 6 months time, we'd ship them
to market to be slaughtered or we'd save
back some of the best ones for oursel.
We'd knock them in the head and eat
them, put it bluntly. And um it always
fascinated me as a teenager that we did
that for those calves and in 6 months
ship them off to be slaughtered or we'd
eat them. And we wanted to live to be a
hundred years of age without any aches
and pains. And guess what? We didn't
take any vitamins or minerals. And that
bothered me. So I asked my dad, I'd say,
'Hey pops, how come you do that for
those calves, you don't do that for us?
And he'd give me this good old Missouri
farm wisdom. He'd say things like, "Shut
up, boy. You're getting this farm fresh
food, and we hope you appreciate it."
And of course, I was very quiet then
because I didn't want to miss out on any
meals. Well, then when I went to school,
I went to the University of Missouri,
the um School of Agriculture, and I got
my degree in agriculture. And it was
very interesting to me that uh I got my
major in animal husbandry and nutrition.
My minor was in field crops and soils.
Then I got into veterary school. As a
freshman veterary student, I learned the
answer to my question. And the answer is
this. We know how to prevent and cure
diseases in animals with nutrition. And
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical. We don't have
hospitalization. Blue Cross Blue Shield.
We don't have um Medicare.
We don't have Hillary to watch out for
us.
If you're going to make money as a
farmer, you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can. Well, to make a long story
short, after I got out of veterary
school, I went to Africa for two years
and I was able to fulfill a boyhood
dream. I was able to be a Frank Buck for
two years and work with Marlon Perkins.
Many of you will remember him from the
Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom and he's
a great gentleman. And after two years
of working with elephants and rhino,
people used to ask me, "Are you a small
animal vet or a large animal vet?" Well,
I tell him I'm a extra-large animal vet
because I work with elephants and
rhinos. Well, after two years, he sent
me a telegram and said, "Would you come
back to the St. Louis Zoo and work with
us? We need a wildlife veterinarian at
the zoo for a special project. We were
given a $7.5 million grant from the um
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo. Well, I was just
overjoyed to do that and so I came back
and and did that and of course I not
only did autopsies for animals that died
in the St. Louis Zoo, but the Brookfield
Zoo in Chicago, the Bronx Zoo in New
York, the National Zoo, the LA Zoo, and
so forth. And my job again was to do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo and look for a
species of animals that was ultra
sensitive to pollution. This is because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do. And so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive to this and use them much like
we did the canaries in the mine. You
know, the old Welsh coal miners used to
put a canary in a little wicker cage and
take it down in the mine. And if methane
gas or carbon monoxide would leak into
the mine, the canary would drop off the
perch and die first. And the men knew to
get out before the mine blew up or they
suffocated.
Well, again, to make a long story short,
uh, over a period of some 12 years, I
did 17,500 autopsies and over 454
species of animals and 3,000 human
beings who lived in close proximity to
zoos. And the thing that I found out was
this. Every animal and every human being
who dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency.
And that fascinated me. It went back
took me back to those calves. I said,
"Gee, that's fascinating. Everybody's
dying of nutritional deficiencies. We
could document this at autopsy both
chemically and biochemically and so
forth and things that you saw with the
eye at the autopsy table. Well, that
fascinated me. And I wrote 75 scientific
articles. I wrote uh eight multi-author
textbooks and one textbook of my own.
Cost 140 bucks for medical students. And
I'm sure the only thing they do is use
them for doors stops.
And I couldn't get anybody excited. I
was on 2020. Uh, I was on 1,700
newspapers.
I was in magazines. I was in every new
uh network TV that you can think of. And
guess what? Couldn't get anybody excited
back in the 60s about nutrition.
So, what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition and my human patients.
And to no surprise to me, it worked.
spent 12 years up in Portland, Oregon in
general practice and um it was very
fascinating. What I'm going to share
with you tonight is what I learned over
those 10 12 years using nutrition with
my human patients. And if you take home
only 10% If you take home only 10% it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery. It will save you a
gob of money. And those of you in
Missouri know what that means. A gob
means a lot.
and will save you and in fact it will
add on many healthful years to your
life. Okay? It'll add many healthful
years to your life. Well, you can't do
this. You can't get these healthful
years and you can't have longevity. You
can't live to your genetic potential
just falling off a stump. Uh you have to
do some things. And the first thing I
have to do is convince you that it is
worth doing these things. I'm going to
start out by convincing you that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 to 140 years. Our genetic potential
for longevity, okay? 120 to 140 years.
There's no less than five cultures whose
people live to be 120 to 140 starts out
in the Tibetans in western China. Uh
these people were popularized back in
um by James Hilton. He wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon. Many of you
will remember reading that was a
Pulitzer Prizewinning book way back
then. And they did a movie of that in
1937. It's a very long movie about three
hours. You can get it from any
blockbuster video. And I would encourage
you to get it and look at it when you
have three hours. It's a great movie.
And the oldest living person that has
some documentation, I'm sure there's a
certain amount of exaggeration in there,
but there is some documentation was a
fellow Dr. Lee Li uh from China along
this Tibetan border. And this fellow
when he was 150 years old, quote
unquote, received a um big certificate
from the Imperial Chinese government. Uh
he was born in 1677.
150 years later, he was given a
certificate by the imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years. And then
when he got to be 200 years, they sent
him another 50 years later, they sent
him another certificate. And supposedly
he died at age 256. and as people of
that nature. He was written up in the
New York Times in 1933 when he died and
the London Times. And so this is fairly
well documented, but he may have only
been 200 years old. Uh I don't know if
he was 256, but this is the um
person that led James Hilton to write
that story. Then uh there's in 1967
or 68 there was a remake of that movie.
It was a color version. And if you
haven't seen that, was called Shangrila.
I'd urge you to see that. Then in
eastern Pakistan, there's a group of
people called the Hunzas. And these
people are very famous for longevity,
120 to 140. And if you've been in
alternative health for any length of
time, you've heard their name at least.
Then in what is now Western Russia, it
used to be the Soviet Union. The Russian
Georgians were made famous during the
70s by Danon Yogurt. You remember the
old Crimea War veterans? They get their
uniform on, they'd hold a saber up and
they would get a cup of Dan and yogurt
and smile a lot and you're supposed to
make the mental leap that it was the Dan
and yogurt that made them live to be
120. Then just south of them, the
Armenians, the abcases and the
Azerbaijanes are famous at least in in
the Soviet Union. They were studied for
some 60 years because they routinely
lived to be 120 to 140. In fact, in 19
uh 73, the January issue of the 19 of
the um uh National Geographic 1973
January uh National Geographic did a
special article on people who live to be
a hundred and are older and they
featured these people and there was a
great pictorial article. You know,
National Geographic is very good about
coming out with pictures and three of
these dozens of pictures that were in
that article. I remember one of them was
a lady who was 136 years old. She was
sitting in a wicker chair with a big
Cuban cigar in one hand and an 8 oz
glass of vodka in the other. And she was
partying. She was having a good time.
She was not in a nursing home all
slouched over and and you know ready to
have somebody take another 2500 bucks
out of her checking account. Uh she was
enjoying herself at 136. Then there was
a semicircle of couples, boy, girl, boy,
girl, boy, girl, and they were
celebrating their 100th and 115th and
120th wedding anniversaries.
Then the third picture that I remember
is a gentleman who was picking tea
leaves up at the timber line in the
Caucasus mountains in Armania. And um he
was listening to a one of these little
transistor radios back then. And
according to his birth records and and
baptismal records, his military records
and the birth records of his children,
uh the National Geographic said that he
was 167 years of age and the oldest
living person at that time. Well, in the
western hemisphere, the Vilabomba
Indians in Ecuador are very famous. They
live in the Andes. And then in
southeastern Peru, my favorites, the
Titty Kakas. I just like them because I
like the name. They're sort of east of
the Machu Picchu, uh, the old community.
The Titty Kakas live around Lake
Tittykaka. And of course, they're very
famous uh for living to be 120 to 140.
Well, in May 11th, just about a month
ago, the oldest living American at this
time and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret Ste.
She was from Radford, Virginia. She died
at age 115.
And she died of a nutritional
deficiency. You can tell that from her
her obituary.
She died of the complications of a fall.
What did she die from? Osteoporosis.
Very good. She died of a calcium
deficiency. She had no heart disease, no
cancer, no diabetes, no other
infirmities, but she died 3 weeks after
a fall because she didn't have enough
calcium. Very interesting. Also, her
daughter said that she had a craving for
sweets until she died. And that's a a
disease called PAH. We'll talk about
that in a little bit. But usually when
you have a craving for chocolate, if
you're a choahholic or a sugarolic, that
means that you have a deficiency of
chromium and venadium. And we'll talk
about that in a minute. Then in a third
world country in Niger in Africa, a
chief by the name of Bower at age 126
was eulogized by one of his wives. So I
assume it was plural. It had many wives.
And she was bragging about him at his
death at age 126. He was still in
possession of all his own teeth.
Okay? So you assume that other faculties
are working too.
Then here's a gentleman uh from Syria at
age 133. He died in July of 1993 and he
was in the Guinness World Book of
Records. Not because he was 133. There's
been many people live longer than that.
Um, not because he remarried for the
fourth time at age 80, but because he
fathered nine children after the age of
80. And this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children, he was
still fathering children after age of
100. And that's what got him into the
Guinness World Book of Records. So
there's still hope for you fellas.
Then those of you who like science, um,
in November of 1993,
those six biosperians came out of that
dome in Arizona. They were in there for
two years. Um, three couples and they
were supposed to eat the perfect food
and recycle the atmosphere and grow
their own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food.
And when they came out, they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
UCLA, University of California at Los
Angeles. And uh they put all this
information, their physical and their
blood work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA. And the medical
computer said that and projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do what they were
doing. So all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 to 140. And when I
grew up on the farm, we could grow 200
uh bushels of corn per acre. And with
all the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did, you could make
a profit if you grew 200 bushels per
acre. But if you only got a 100 bushels
per acre and put out that same effort
and the same fertilizer cost, you'd lose
money.
And so I want you to think about it. The
average lifespan for an American today
is 75.5.
The average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58.
You want to gain 20 years statistically,
just don't go to medical school. You
want to live to be 120 to 140, there's
only two basic things, real simple, two
things to remember. Number one, you have
to avoid the pitfalls. You have to not
step on the landmines, I call it. And
those of you in the military, you know
what that means. Um, you do something
stupid like step on one of those things,
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily.
And of course, if you play Russian
roulette or smoke excessively or drink
excessively or wear a black sweatuit and
run down the middle of the highway at
2:00 in the morning, you're going to get
struck by a car. Uh, all of those things
are foolhardy, but it's amazing how many
tens of thousands of people die in
America from doing those stupid things
every year. The last thing I will share
with you on that subject of avoiding the
landmines, I'd suggest very strongly to
you that you avoid going to doctors. And
I'm going to back up that statement,
which is a pretty strong statement, with
a um statement from Ralph Nater's group
in January of 1993,
just about a year and a half ago. Uh
January 13th, he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals.
And it was 1500page report, this
three-year study. And I'm not going to
waste your time or mine by going over
the whole thing word for word, but the
bottom line says a lot. The bottom line
says a lot. And here it is. Quote, this
is from Ralph Nater. Now, he's a
consumer advoc advocate for those of you
who don't know him who watches out for
us. Quote, 300,000 Americans are killed
each year in hospitals alone as a result
of medical negligence. Unquote. I'm
going to read that figure again because
it's a huge figure. Quote, 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence. Unquote. Now, he didn't say
slipped away quietly out of neglect in a
corner somewhere while they're waiting
for an X-ray. He used the word killed.
When you use the word killed, that means
there was a procedure the doctor was
doing went wrong somehow. That means
that they gave them a wrong
prescription. They put a decimal point
in the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage. These people were
killed.
300,000. To appreciate how big a figure
that is, you have to compare that with
our military losses in Vietnam over 10
years where we lost 56,000 people over
10 years or an average of only 5,600 a
year on a field of battle where people
had guns and artillery and explosives
trying to kill each other. And millions
of people poured out into the streets
and protested that war. We had political
anarchy in the last three years of the
war. Uh, students took over universities
and colleges with guns and explosives.
National Guardsmen shot students at Kent
State in Ohio. We chased a president out
of the presidency
for 5,600 military personnel a year. And
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us a year
according to Ralph Nater. And I believe
him. He has no axe to grind. And you can
go out in the street any day of the week
in any city and there isn't even a crazy
street preacher out there with a sign
that says protect us from doctors.
I want you to think about that folks.
That's number one. You have to avoid
stepping on the landmine. So there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can or preventing disease so you
don't have to get treated. Now the
second thing you have to do, number two,
is you have to do the positive things.
You have to do the positive things. And
I'm going to start out here by just
putting a figure up on the board. It's
the number 90. And you need 90 nutrients
in your diet every day. You need 60
minerals.
You need 16 vitamins.
You need 12 essential amino acids or
protein building blocks. And you need
three essential fatty acids. You need 90
nutrients in your daily diet. Otherwise,
you're going to get a deficiency disease
if you don't have them in complete
numbers in optimal amounts.
Well, I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college.
I had a clipboard. We didn't have
computers back then. So, I had a
clipboard and I I was one of those funny
guys with glasses and would walk up and
down in the student union there in
Colombia and say, "Do you take vitamins
and minerals?" I was still fascinated by
that. And and of course, people would
kind of look at you crazy and say,
"Well, yeah, I take vitamin E." And I'd
wait for them to come up with the other
89 and they didn't. They just, "Oh, I
take vitamin E." Well, today if you ask
people, "Do you take food supplements?"
They say, "Oh, yeah. I take Tums."
Because that's what, you know, they hear
all the time. Well, again, you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it.
But the newspapers know and the
magazines and TV and radio knows that
we're interested in health and longevity
and and supplements. So, they all talk
to us, not because the medical
profession has asked them to do that in
theirstead. The medical profession
doesn't say, "Hey, we're so busy saving
people with surgery and chemotherapy and
radiation and pharmaceuticals. Would you
please educate the people on nutrition?"
They do it because it sells newspapers.
Well, my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th,
1992. And if you haven't read it, I'd
urge you to get it out of a school
library or public library and photocopy
it. Stick one copy on the door in the
bathroom and one on the refrigerator.
It's a cover article. It says, "The real
power of vitamins. New research shows
they may help fight cancer, heart
disease, and the ravages of aging.
Again, there are six positive pages in
here. There's only one negative
sentence, and it was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article, "What do you think? What do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people as food supplements?" And
here's what the doctor said. Quote,
"Popping vitamins doesn't do you any
good?" sniffs Dr. Victor Herbert, a
professor of medicine at New York City's
Mount Sinai Medical School. we get all
the vitamins we need in our diets and
taking supplements just gives you
expensive urine."
Well, to give you a Missouri translation
of that, that means you're just peeing
away your dollars if you take vitamins
and minerals. You might as well wad up
your dollars and throw them in the
toilet and flush them away because
you're not getting any redeeming value
from it. Those quacks are just taking
your money for those vitamins and
minerals. That's what he was trying to
say. Got published. So, it must be true,
right?
I'll tell you what, after having done
those 17,500 autopsies and 454 species
of animals from around the world and
3,000 humans and liking to be healthy
myself and having children and
grandchildren in the not too distant
future great grandchildren, I'd rather
pee out 50 cents or a dollar a day worth
of excess vitamins and minerals is
pretty cheap insurance. Because if you
don't invest in yourself to the tune of
a buck a day for vitamins and minerals,
guess what? you're gonna invest in the
lifestyle of a MD somewhere because when
you pay the medical doctor your fee for
going to see him, not one penny of that
goes to study how to diagnose or treat
or prevent a catastrophic disease in a
little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer or prostate
cancer in adults.
Guess what that money goes for? Pays a
doctor's mortgage. Makes his Mercedes
payment. It pays a tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at Hav. You know
where Hav is up in Baston?
Pays a tuition for his kids to go to law
school at Yale. I believe because we've
made doctors wealthy. Between 1776 and
the Second World War, the US government
spent $80 million on healthcare and
healthc care research and studies. Right
now, we're $1.2 2 trillion dollar a year
for healthcare and it's free. We all
know it's free, right?
I like that lady. She says, "Like heck,
it's not free, but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff." Well,
I'll tell you what, if we use the human
type medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock, your
hamburger costs $275 a pound.
On the other hand, if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans, your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be $10 a month. You take your
choice. Well, I believe since we've made
them wealthy through insurance programs
and government subsidies, I believe they
owe us something. And I believe they owe
us at least as much as the uh industries
do according to, for instance, recall
notices. This was started, of course, I
don't know, 25 years ago when Ralph
Nater learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a rear
end gas tank that would blow up when you
got hit from behind at 20 mph, fry
everybody in the car. And when people
complained to Ford Motor Company, they
said, "Well, you're just dumb for
getting in a car accident. We're not
going to pay you for that." Well, Ralph
Nater says, "No, it's a faulty design."
So, he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and through a
court order forced Ford Motor Company to
send everybody a uh recall notice with a
registered letter. Bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing. But they
kill 300,000 a year and nobody protests
as long as we get ours free. And that
scares me, that attitude. At any rate,
I've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple years. We'll go through them
quickly. Number one is ulcers. How many
of you ever heard that ulcers is caused
by stress?
Okay, everybody's heard that if you
don't raise your hand, you got
Alzheimer's or you're fibbon, right?
Well, we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterary industry that uh ulcers, at
least in pigs, was caused by a bacteria
called helicoacttor pylori. And of
course, we couldn't get one of these
highric stomach surgeons from Mayo
Clinic. In fact, we always used to yell,
"Hold the mayo" when they'd say stuff
like that. And otherwise, your pork
chops would be $275 a pound to pay for
that kind of surgery. And we learned
that with a trace mineral called
bismouth and the tetracycline antibiotic
that we could prevent and then and cure
those stomach ulcers in pigs without
surgery. And so that's what we did. Cost
five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with bismouth the trace mineral
and tetracycline. Well, the National
Institutes of Health, now not the
National Inquirer, but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February of this year, February 1994,
and said ulcers are caused by a bacteria
called helicoacttor pylori, not stress.
And they can be cured. They actually
used the cure word in this news release.
Medical researchers never do that. They
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial. They use the cure
word National Institutes of Health and
they say can be cured with a combination
of the trace mineral bismouth and
tetracycling.
Well, for those of you who don't know
what bismouth comes in, you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore.
It's pink about 2.95 for an 8 oz bottle
and it's called Pepto Bismol. So, a
teaspoon a day full of Pepto-Bismol and
some ory calf scour pellets. You can
take care of ulcers.
Now you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittleled on. That's your
choice.
Then what's the number two cause of
death in Americans? Terrible disease
called cancer. Right now doctors get
information on cancer. You'd think
they'd photocopy that. When they send
you that bill, they should send you some
photocopies of this stuff. Well, in
September of 1993, the um National
Cancer Institute, not the National
Inquirer, but the National Cancer
Institute and the um Hav Medical School
up in Baston did a study on cancer
patients and they came out and they said
an anti-cancer diet was found. Well, any
rate, they picked China to do this study
because in one province, Henan province
in China, they have the highest rate of
cancer in the whole world. They took
29,000 people for 5 years in this study.
And what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans. Now that's a trivial
amount. For instance, they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the RDA or
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 milligrams. Double that's going
to be 120 milligrams. You can't go into
a health food store and find a vitamin C
tablet or capsule for less than 500
milligrams for an adult. And of course,
Lionus Pauling, the gentleman with two
Nobel prizes, says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C,
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day.
Well, all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago, are all
dead. And today, Linus Pauling, still
94, and he works 14 hours a day, 7 days
a week on his ranch in the big su in
California and teaches at the University
of California, San Francisco. So, you
have to make up your choice whether
you're going to listen to the dead
doctors or Lionus Pauling.
Your choice. Okay, vitamin C, double the
RDA, nothing happened. Vitamin A, double
the RDA, nothing happened. Zinc,
riboflavin, the trace mineral
malibdinum, nasin, nothing happened. In
one group, they got a major benefit. In
this group, they got three nutrients at
one time. They got vitamin E, they got
beta carotene, and the trace mineral
selenium. That those three were at
double the RDA. And if you get a half a
percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment, you've made a
major improvement in humanity's life.
And so these articles get published. So
I want you to remember that statistic. A
half a percent is major benefit. Well,
in this group that received the vitamin
E, beta carotene, and selenium for 5
years, deaths from all causes were
reduced by 9%. Almost 10 out of every
hundred or one out of every 10 who were
going to die in that 5 years from any
cause survived.
Then cancers, all cancers, 13% survived
who would have died without those three
nutrients.
So 13 out of a 100red lived who would
have died. And then the type of cancer
that was most prevalent in Henan
province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died. 21 out of
a 100red lived. Now to me those are
significant numbers. And your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America should have sent every one of
you a photocopy that at least given you
information. Even if he doesn't want to
give you the advice, give you the
information. Let you make up your own
mind. Well, here's one I think is funny.
On one hand, and on the other side, it
tells you the attitude of physicians.
This has to do with arthritis. It was in
um September 24th, 1993 that it was
released. Again, it was from the Hav
Medical School in the Baston VA
hospital. How many of you in here have
ever been to a VA hospital? Anybody in
this room? Okay, good. Well, you know,
the people who've been to a VA hospital,
you have two opportunities to give your
life for your country. once on the field
of battle and the others in the VA
hospital. Right.
Well, at any rate, the title of the
release was chicken protein halts the
swelling and pain of arthritis in a
patient trial. And what they did, they
took people who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis.
These people got gold shots, meotate,
they got uh aspirin, predinazone,
cortisone, everything else you can think
of, physical therapy, and the only thing
left for them was joint replacement
surgery. Okay. Now, before Harvard
Medical School, the VA hospital was
going to give it to them, they said,
"Look, we're looking for some people who
are willing to suffer for 90 more days,
just three months, because we want to
try something, a short-term experiment."
And they got 29 volunteers. And what
they did for those 29 volunteers who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis was they gave
them a heaping teaspoon full of groundup
dried chicken cartilage in their orange
juice every morning. Just a heaping
teaspoon of groundup chicken cartilage.
And in 10 days, according to Harvard
Medical School, all the pain and
inflammation was gone. These are people
who didn't respond in any way to medical
treatment.
In 30 days, they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened. And
in 90 days, 3 months, they had maximum
return of function.
Now, here's the funny part. The funny
part comes by a statement of the guy who
was the director of that study from
Harvard Medical School. And here's what
he said. Quote, listen to the words,
very important. Quote, "After 3 months,
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial." Unquote. Because it worked,
chicken cartilage had become a drug.
You can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule, 20 patients,
and you can just see him calculating,
right?
That means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken,
throw away the skin and the meat, and
eat the ends off the bones, you're
practicing medicine without a license.
And if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night, in
the dark of the night, and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave,
you know you're manufacturing a
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in jail.
Well, if that's a little messy for you
and you don't want to pay those lawyer
fees, you can go into any grocery store
and get some Knox gelatin. Women know
about Nox gelatin because it's good for
your fingernails and your hair and your
skin. It has the raw materials for
chicken cartilage. Has the raw material
for your cartilage
because made out of beef cartilage and
beef tendon. And if you take two of
those little half ounce envelopes a day
in your orange juice and you take it
with an ounce per 100 pounds of body
weight of colloidal minerals,
next time I come by here in three
months, you're going to run up on this
stage and hug me and kiss me if you got
arthritis.
How many of you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease? Everybody's heard
about it today. 50 years ago, when I was
a little kid, there was no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease. It's a new disease,
one of those things that just sort of
happened. Now, it's a major disease. One
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease. Pretty scary.
Well, we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry how to prevent and cure
in the early stages Alzheimer's disease
and livestock. Can you imagine how much
a farmer would lose if the pigs were all
laying there scratching their head
saying, "Why am I here?
Where is the feed box?" Because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day, you're losing money. Right? So, we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease. And we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil. You say, Wallick,
that's crazy. High doses of vitamin E.
Well, you should have got a recall
notice from your doctor in July of 1992
because the University of California, I
mean, we're talking about a
sophisticated research medical school
here. University of California, San
Diego came out and said vitamin E eases
memory loss in Alzheimer's victims. Now,
they're only 50 years behind on that
from veterary medicine. So, you might be
safer going to a veterinarian.
Then, how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone? Anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone? Okay, I see a few
in here. What's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone? Give up
calcium. No dairy. No dairy. None of
those vitamin mineral things with
calcium in them because they had the
stupid naive ignorant belief that's
pretty intense. They have the stupid,
ignorant, naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat. When in fact, it comes
from your own bones. When you have a
raging calcium deficiency, a raging
osteoporosis, then you get kidney
stones. We learned a thousand years ago
in writing in the agricultural industry,
if you wanted to prevent kidney stones
and livestock, you better give them more
calcium, you better give them more
magnesium and more boron.
Now, the reason is, of course, bulls and
rams, male cattle and sheep, have
special anatomy. When they get a kidney
stone, they die. They call water belly.
They die. When you and I get a kidney
stone, we just wish we were dead. But no
farmer is dumb enough to pay for the
feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market. So, we learned how to prevent
those things. Well, you should have got
a recall notice from your doctor,
especially you people who've had kidney
stones. Your urologist should have sent
a notice to you. This was uh about 15
months ago, March of 1993. It says uh
calcium limits kidney stone risk. And
this is from the Hav Medical School up
in Baston. By the way, in a study that
turns conventional medical wisdom on its
head, researchers have found that people
whose diets are rich in calcium run a
reduced risk of developing kidney
stones. In a study of more than 45,000
people that who were ranked into five
categories, the group that had the most
calcium had no kidney stones. So, it
took him a thousand years to catch up.
Now, about five years ago, when I
started out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America,
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and all over, I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh doing this. Last
year, I was on the road 300 days out of
the year. 300 out of 365 days. And so, I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me. Every time I get a
little wacko, I could go in my room and
do this hobby and I'd be okay. You know,
it' be kind of like having a little
piece of home with me wherever I went. I
wanted to have a hobby that would uh uh
help other people. I didn't want to
collect baseball cards because I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles because good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else.
And um I couldn't take my compost pile.
I like to garden and the hotels don't
like that, you know. So I decided I was
going to collect obituaries of doctors
and lawyers.
Now, as crazy as that sounds, remember I
told you that doctors live to an average
age of 58 and we live to 75.5. And
here's a group of people, professionals,
who pontificate you and tell you, well,
this is what you need to do. You need to
give up salt and uh no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things. And they
die at age 58 on the average. And of
course, all those people who live to be
120 to 140, they put a chunk of rock
salt in their tea every day and they
drink 40 cups of tea a day. 40 chunks of
rock salt and they cook with butter
instead of olive oil and they live to be
120. So who are you going to believe?
The people who live to be 58 or the
people who live to be 120? It's your
choice. Anyway, I got a few of them
here. Some of my favorites. This is Dr.
Stuart Cartwright, age 38. He dropped
dead in his home. He was a family
practitioner of a ruptured aneurysm.
That's a ballooning of an artery. That's
a weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and arteries. Just
like when you hit a chuck hole with your
car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon.
He dropped dead like he was poleaxed.
Okay. Right in his home from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. Now, we learned in 19
oh I think it was uh 57
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency.
We had a pilot project, 250,000 turkeys,
and we made complete food pellets where
you put all the 90 nutrients in there.
And in the first 13 weeks, fully half of
those turkeys died, 125,000 of them.
Farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket.
They took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy, and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured aortic aneurysm. So, they
doubled the amount of copper in there.
And the next year they tried to raise
500,000 turkeys. And they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm. And they ran that experiment
in mice and rats and rabbits and dogs
and cats and uh calves and sheep and
pigs and whatnot. And guess what? They
found out that there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency. Gray hair is the first sign
when you start getting gray hair,
regardless of your age, you got a copper
deficiency. You get skin wrinkles
because the elastic fibers in your skin
are going. those little crows feet
around your eyes and facial and body
skin wrinkles. You look like you're a
little prune drying up. Okay.
Then of course there's the um uh
varicose veins.
Varicose veins. That's caused by an
elastic fiber breakdown. Then of course
parts of your body begin to sag under
your arms, your breast, your bellies,
your legs. All this stuff starts
sagging. And you can go to a cosmetic
surgeon and a plastic surgeon if you
want, but it's a lot cheaper and a lot
more effective and a lot safer if you
just take some copper. Okay. Well, Dr.
Cartwright may have had a medical
degree, but he didn't have expensive
urine, so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from. Then here's
one. This fellow, he was a doctor's
doctor, Dr. Martin Carter. He almost
made it. He died at age 57. Um he got
his medical degree from Havit Medical
School and his PhD in medicine from Yale
of course um he was autopsied by the
best because he was a doctor's doctor
who said quote the cause of death was a
ruptured aortic aneurysm said Dr. Jules
Hersh of the Rockefeller University
Hospital. What did he die from? Copper
deficiency. See, he didn't have
expensive urine either.
Then here's an attorney. She was so
famous. She was from Detroit, age 44,
Ellen Joyce Alter. Uh she was in the New
York Times obituary. She made the big
time. And uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs. All these
gals want steel buns, you know, doing
their little exercises.
But she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm.
When they don't do an autopsy, the
symptoms could be called a stroke or uh
subdural hemorrhage, but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm,
which is a copper deficiency. She didn't
have expensive urine. How many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Burgerer? Stuart
Burgerer. He he wrote five best-selling
books on health and diets and nutrition.
Uh he got his medical degree from Tus
Medical School, which is a very fine
medical school in Boston, not too far
away from uh Harvard Medical School. And
the books he wrote included the
Southampton diet for weight loss. He
wrote Forever Young, 20 years younger in
20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist. And he died at age 40.
How'd you like to follow his dietary
practices? He died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency. The same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease.
And any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and bozie
and so forth. And Dr. Steuart Burgerer,
a guy who wrote five be best-selling
books on nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency.
He didn't have expensive urine.
Now, you can prevent totally prevent
cardiammyopathy for 10 cents a day. And
if we don't do it, we're malignant dumb.
I like to call it. You're malignant dumb
if you don't take in 10 cents a day
worth of selenium. It's a waste of your
life. That's one of those landmines you
can avoid. The medical treatment of
choice for cardiammyopathy is a heart
transplant. Cost $750,000.
I want you to think about that. They get
the heart free from a donor.
They get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives. They use $2.50 worth
of suture material
and they charge us $750,000
for that procedure. Now, 6 months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake, they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for $4.
They put them in jail for price gouging
for selling them a gallon of water for
four bucks. Now, to me, that's
entrepreneurialism. You know, that's
being in business for yourself. If you
had a a way to distill water and make
water and you had a car and you could
get in there and sell those people a
gallon of water for four bucks, hey,
more power to you because if you go to a
7-Eleven and buy a quart of Evian water,
it's $1.29.
So, four of those quarts is five bucks.
[Music]
Kind of interesting, isn't it? They said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified. Well, talk about
a person who needs a new heart. They're
terrified. $750,000.
We should put those doctors in jail. But
we bow to them because, oh, that's
high-tech medicine. Out of 270 million
people in America, you save about 50 a
year. Is that cost effective? I don't
think so. I don't think so. Any rate,
Dr. Steuart Burer didn't have expensive
urine. Here's the last one. And many of
you may know this woman. Her name is Dr.
Gail Clark. She was age 47. She was the
chief cardiologist of the West St. Louis
County Group of Hospitals. Uh she was
the chief cardiologist for the um St.
Mary's Health Center in Richmond Heights
in St. Louis County. She was age 47.
Guess what? She died from heart attack.
A cardiammyopathy heart attack. You can
just see her walking down the hall.
She's got the stethoscope around her
neck. You know, this is their little
status symbol. Got my stethoscope around
my neck. Back when I was in school, they
folded it up very bravely and put it in
their pocket. Boom. She falls down. She
has a heart attack right in the hall.
And of course, the nurses scoop her up
and put her on a gurnie and they call
the technicians and another doctor. Code
three, code three, code blue, whatever
it is. And they whip her into the room.
And you can hear them. Let's say you're
a cardiac patient. You're laying there.
You're all hooked up to the monitors and
the IVs and and you hear them say,
"Okay, tear your clothes off. Okay,
stand back. Didn't work. Turn it up.
Stand back." And then you hear that
terrible sound when you know that the
treatment didn't work.
the flat line when you know the heart is
gone and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say nurse nurse what
happened next door and she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist of this hospital age 47 Dr.
Gail Clark just died of a
cardiammyopathy heart attack you can see
all the patients are holding their gowns
and they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their checkbooks and everything and
their plastic credit cards because they
don't want to get what Dr. Gail Clark
got
to me. The Reader's Digest is a magazine
that never says anything negative or bad
about anybody or any group. It's the
sweetest little magazine that ever was.
The September 1993 issue features an
article. It says, "Can you trust your
doctor?" It lists 12 ways that doctors
scam your money. And I'll let you read
11 of them yourself. I'll give you the
worst one.
In addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization, in addition to all
those fees, doctors get a kickback from
the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals. They get a
kickback of $421 every time they send
you in for a CAT scan or an MRI.
And doctors tell you, "Oh, we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something,
you know, one in 10 billion, you're
going to sue me. So, I do this just to
protect myself." Well, if it was just to
protect themselves and you knew them and
they knew you, 90% of the people say,
"Oh, just skip it, doc, if you don't
really think it's necessary. Let's save
the money." But they got something more
than defensive medicine to worry about.
They get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in for an MRI
or a CAT scan. Well, when I practiced
for 12 years up in Portland, somebody
come to me with a terrible headache,
never had one, I'd just walk up to them
and tap them on the sinuses, and if they
collapse to their knees, I know they had
a sinus headache. Oh, doc. Why'd you do
that? Well, I just wanted that's a cheap
lab test, you know.
Then if they had Thank you.
If they had blood dripping out of their
nose,
if they had blood dripping out of their
nose, I'd take a $35 X-ray to see if
they had a cancer in there.
35 bucks in a free lab test as opposed
to 421 bucks. If I wanted to make that
421 bucks, I'd have been a good thief.
What I'd have done, I'd build a chute
right into that CAT scan machine because
I knew how to build chuts living on a
farm. And I'd have gone out in the
street and I'd have got every homeless
person. I'd line them up in them shoots
and I'd put soup and a Big Mac at the
end of that tube, you know, and I'd say,
"I'm going to buy you a $150 dinner. I'm
a good guy. I'm going to buy you a $150
dinner. You just got to go through the
shootute, go through that tube, and you
get your sandwich and your soup." Man,
they'd be flowing through there, maybe a
hundred a day. And I could start adding
some things up. It'd be a lot of fun.
Any rate, the average doctor gets
$228,660
a year in CAT scan kickbacks. A quarter
of a million dollars a year. And any
other industry, if you do that,
politicians,
lawyers,
businessmen,
stock brokers, they get put in jail. But
doctors, it's okay
because insurance pays for it. Hillary
will pay for it. We don't mind if they
steal this blind. It's free. Well, I
remember I told you I was going to tell
you about PAH.
PAH is a funny disease, PICA. I'm not
talking about the type style that you
see in typewriters and computers. But
PAH is a disease that farmers know
about. Uh in horses, it's called
cribbing. When they chew on the feed
bunk, the wooden feed bunk, you know,
you better give them some minerals,
otherwise they're going to eat that feed
bunk. Also, uh, in cattle, dairy cattle
especially, where they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the
time, intensive milking, uh, you'll see
them picking up big rocks in the creek
and chewing on them, or they'll chew on
bobwire, or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something, or a
shingle. That's called pah. And a good
farmer, a husband, knows you better give
them some minerals, otherwise they're
going to eat the barn or something. In
human beings, we see this at funny
times. Pregnant women are notorious for
pah. uh in the middle of the night,
they'll elbow their husband and say,
"Hey, you better get up. I want some uh
pickles and ice cream. They're craving
minerals because that fetus is pulling
minerals out of their body. They need
some more minerals." And so it's it's
recognized as a craving for things like
sweets and salt and so forth. We see
this in pregnant women. I used to have
people come to my practice and they say,
"Doc, do I need to go see a shrink?" I
said, "Why is that?" "Well, I wake up in
the middle of the night and I I go
outside with a spoon and I eat dirt and
no, that's okay. just make sure it's
clean dirt.
Then they say, "My my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box." And
then in housing projects, little kids
will eat lead paint off the walls and
they get lead poison, get learning
disabilities and bone problems and
anemia and we're good. So we spend $5
million to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint.
And all we have to do is give those kids
10 cents a day worth of minerals. will
be better for him and save us 5 million
bucks. It's your tax money and if we
allow them to throw them away those
dollars is kind of interesting. Any
rate, if you have a selenium deficiency
and you don't want to wait until you get
cardiammyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it, if you
look on your hands and look in the
mirror in your face, if you have liver
spots or age spots, and I see quite a
few from here,
you have an early selenium deficiency.
That's called free radical damage. And
fortunately for you, if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
colloidal selenium, in four to six
months, those will all go away. You'll
reverse that in four to 6 months. And
when they go away on the outside,
they're going away on the inside. In
your brain and your heart and your liver
and your kidneys. Then if you have low
blood sugar, how many in this room have
low blood sugar? Anybody in here have
low blood sugar? Okay, about 10%. How
many of you ever seen a hyperactive kid
who gets on sugar?
Okay, about everybody in the room.
People who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics. There's good ones and bad
ones. You know, the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks, they just
go off in a corner and go to sleep,
right? Same way with somebody with low
blood sugar. They eat a big meal or they
eat a piece of pie, three hours later,
they clunk out and go to sleep. Then
there's bad alcoholics. They're the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody. They punch holes in the
wall and you know big brave fellows and
they kick their wife and kick the dog
and take the chainsaw and cut their
neighbor's tree down and all these wild
things and drive reckless down the roads
and kill people. Those are the bad
drunks. Well, people who have blood
sugar problems, there's bad blood sugar
people, too. They get a little crazy.
Okay, I don't know how many of you
remember the Twinkie defense, right?
Remember where somebody murdered two
people and he claimed he ate a Twinkie
three hours before he murdered him. So
they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar. Now don't any of you try that.
Well, chromium and venadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems. Low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time, you develop
diabetes. Chromium and venadium. Then a
tin deficiency. The early symptoms of a
tin deficiency are male pattern
baldness. I see a lot of tin deficiency
in this room. Yes.
And if you let it go on for any length
of time, you get deafness.
Then there's a boron deficiency. And you
gals should know about boron because it
helps you keep the calcium you take in
in your bones so you don't get
osteoporosis.
Boron.
Also, it helps you make estrogen. It
helps you fellas make testosterone. If
you don't take in enough boron, you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause. Okay? You're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms. You fellas don't get enough
boron, can't make testosterone, you
won't know whether to lead or follow on
the dance floor.
You're going to be confused.
She's saying he's got a boron
deficiency.
Then in laboratory, oh, I should tell
you too, we said this on the show today.
Those of you may not have heard it. Some
of you didn't hear the whole show. The
first symptoms of a zinc deficiency is
you lose your sense of smell and your
taste. You say, "Oh, you know, food just
doesn't taste good anymore and you don't
have a cold or anything like that." And
you say, your wife says, "Well, aren't
you excited about dinner? I spent the
whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner." He said, "Well, I didn't smell
anything when I walked in." You know,
he's got a zinc deficiency. Well, in
laboratory animals, there's some seven
rare earths. These rare earths are trace
minerals you need in lesser amounts than
you need trace minerals, and they
actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals. They've not been
proven in humans yet, but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it. They're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium, right? So, I'm just going
to do it. Didn't kill any laboratory
animals. It just doubles their life, and
it's not a drug. These rare earths are
called lanthinum, praiodime, neodymium,
samarium, europium, yerbium, and
thulium. There must be a reason why
they're named after Old Testament
cities. Well, remember I told you we
needed 90 nutrients. We need 60
minerals. We need 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, and three
essential fatty acids. And of course,
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids. Plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins,
amino acids, and fatty acids. But you
have to eat 15 to 25 different plants a
day in the right combinations to make
this happen. Theoretically, it's
possible, but most Americans don't do
it. The average American thinks if they
eat some potato buds out of a Betty
Crocker box, they're eating a vegetable.
Okay? So, you got to be careful what
you're considering a vegetable. Then, of
course, people want to do right by their
doctor and they eat low-fat turkey
breast and they put a half a jar of
mayonnaise on there and they put it
between two slices of Wonder Styrofoam
bread. Remember that stuff you can
insulate your house with and put in your
shoes when you get a hole in your shoe?
I remember when I was a kid 50 years
ago, it was a lot of fun because we have
Wonderbread. We didn't have TVs back
then on the farm. We didn't even have
dryers that went round and round. So,
the only thing you could do in the
winter time was sit in the kitchen and
wondered a loaf of Wonderbread and had
the blue and red and green yellow
balloons on there. And if you read the
label as many times as I do, you know,
it said things like helps build bodies
at 12 ways. And about 15 years later,
the FDA made them change it to help
build your body eight ways. Now, if you
go to the store and look at Wonderbread
Wrappers, it just says Wonderbread. So
it kind of gives you a clue.
So even though this is theoretically
possible, it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins, amino
acids, and fatty acids in proper
proportions from your diet. And so if
your life is as valuable to you as mine
is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me, I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 to
140 if you don't. You're just not going
to do it. Now, minerals are another
story. We have a tragic story when it
comes to minerals because plants cannot
make minerals in any way, shape, or
form. If they're not in the soil
anymore, they're not in our plants. We
have for you when you leave a free copy
of a summary of US Senate document 264.
US Senate document 264 is from the 74th
Congress, second session. And it says
that our farm soils and our rain soils
are depleted of minerals. And the crops,
the grains, the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and rain soils
are minally deficient. And the people
who eat them get mineral deficiency
diseases. And the only way to prevent
and cure them is with mineral
supplements. That's US Senate document
264, 74th Congress, second session. It
was written and printed by the US
Congress in 1936,
58 years ago. You think it's gotten any
better? No, it has not gotten any
better. It's only gotten worse. And the
reason is if you guys do what we did and
people continue to do is we put NPK on
our land, nitrogen, phosphorus,
potassium. And you see it as these three
numbers in many combinations of of um
ratios. And these represent percentages
of these three nutrients, nitrogen,
phosphorus, potassium. And those of you
who don't have any experience on farms,
the reason why we do this is farmers get
paid for tons and bushels. There's no
subsidy that encourages people to put 60
minerals back in the soil. You get paid
for tons and bushels. And for 40 bucks
an acre, you can get the maximum yield
in tons and bushels. It only takes 5 to
10 years to deplete the land of minerals
because every time you harvest a crop,
those plants pull minerals out of the
soil. Many pounds per acre every time
you haul a crop out. So soon those
minerals are gone. And if you only put
back in three and you take out 60, it's
like a checking account. If you only put
three bucks in your checking account
every month and write checks for 60,
what's going to happen to your checks?
Boing, boing, boing. They bounce.
Exactly. Well, I can tell you that our
health is bouncing right now to the tune
of $1.2 trillion dollar a year because
there's no more minerals left in our
soil. It's our responsibility, each and
every one of us, to be responsible for
our health and consciously take in these
minerals. I have a lot of people ask me,
what did these people do thousands of
years ago? They didn't even have
commercial fertilizers. What did they
do? These societies that had long live
people and whatnot. I want you to think
about the Egyptians, the Chinese, uh,
people from India that lived around
these great rivers, the Nile River, the
Ganges River, um, the Yalu River in
China. And what used to happen was every
year or so it would flood just like it
did here in northern Missouri last year.
And every time it flooded, guess what
would happen? It would bring silt or
rock dust from mountains from 500 or
thousand miles away. And those people
would pray to every god they had, the
water god, the sky god, the wind god,
the rock god to flood. We pray don't
flood. They used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
winter time and it would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
grain was very valuable. King Philip,
who is the father of uh Alexander the
Great, married the 12-year-old child
queen of Egypt, Cleopatra. She didn't
look like Elizabeth Taylor, all made up
and beautiful costumes. She was a little
flatchested teeny bopper, not very sexy.
But Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world.
And if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great, he needed the best
wheat in the world. So he could march 20
hours a day, fight for six hours, and
win. If they used the wheat from the
depleted soils in Greece, they couldn't
go 20 minutes without saying, "Mommy,
pick me up." Can you imagine these big
Greek soldiers? Oh, my legs hurt. Pick
me up. And so they knew the best place
to get wheat was from Egypt.
It was those floods that gave them those
minerals. And all those cultures that
came up with all the great art and all
the great technology came from those pe
places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition, more minerals. I heard
somebody say, "Very good." Well, you're
getting the picture. Well, what I'm
going to do here is I'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals,
just a couple of them, so you get the
idea. It applies to all of them. Let's
just pick out a common one like calcium.
Everybody knows about calcium. Calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases. They're just
different names. They're named after
people like Bell's palsy. Bell's palsy
is, you know, everybody knows about
that. One side of your face sags. It's
not a true stroke. It just affects your
facial muscles. It's caused by a calcium
deficiency. We'll talk about in a little
bit, but everybody knows about this one,
osteoporosis.
It's the number 10 killer of adults in
the United States. It's very expensive.
would cost you $35,000 each for each hip
to replace. It's okay. It's free.
Insurance or Medicare or Hillary will
pay for it. Cost you $70,000 for both
hips. As expensive as it is and the
number 10 killer, remember Mrs. SK from
Radford, Virginia, aged 115 years of
age, she died of complications of a
fall. We don't have osteoporosis in
animals. And it's because of farmers. We
don't have osteoporosis in animals. Goes
like this. you have a a pasture with a
hundred cows in it and this year you
didn't have any calves, you can't repay
your operating loan. You're in trouble,
right? Because you paid for the feed and
the vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this that and the
other. You don't have any calves. You
can't pay back the oper operating load
and make any money. So, you call the vet
out and you say, "Do I get rid of these
cows? What happened here?" And he
examines the cows. He says, "Nothing
wrong with them." Says, "Let me look at
the bull." And he said, "Aha, here's
your problem. That bull has osteoporosis
of both hips. Can't breed the cows.
Didn't have any calves. He says, "I'll
tell you what though." He says, "You
give me $70,000." He says, "I'll put two
new hips in that bull and next year
you'll have some calves." Well, the
first thing that farmer says is, "Stand
back, Doc." Boom.
He blows that bull away with a deer
rifle. And while the kids are grinding
the kid the uh while the kids are
grinding the bull up with um a grinder
and cutting roast and steaks off that
bull. The farmer's chewing on a straw
and saying, "Now, Doc pushes Stson up a
little bit." And he says, "You know, he
says, uh, you know, I wasn't going to
pay you $70,000 for that old bull." He
says, "I can get a new bull every year
for 70 years for that." He says, "But
every once in a while, I get a bull that
throws good calves. I'd like to keep
them. Is there any way I can prevent
that osteoporosis thing for happening to
a good bull?" He says, "Well, yeah." He
says, "If you'll give a bull calf 10
cents worth of calcium every day after
he's weaned, he'll never get
osteoporosis." Firm said, "Wait a
minute, doc. You mean if I give that
bull 10 cents a day worth of calcium
from the time he's weaned, I can prevent
a $70,000
disaster?" Oh, yeah. It's that simple.
He says, "You mean all I have to do is
give up a half a cup of coffee a day to
do that?" He says, "Yeah, that's it." He
says, "I choose that one." He said,
"I'll give up the half a cup of coffee."
And that's what we have to think like.
Okay. Then there's receding gums.
Dentist and perodontist will tell you
that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums, you better floss and
brush after every meal. If you believe
that works, I have some oceanfront
property in Montana to sell you. If you
all know your geography, you know that
doesn't work. Now, as a veterinarian,
I've seen hundreds of thousands of
animals of all kinds. mice, rats,
rabbits, dogs, cats, sheep, pigs,
horses, lions, and tigers, and bears,
and they don't get receding gums. And
they don't floss. Now, they do get funky
breath, but they don't get receding
gums. Well, if you want to smell some,
you just let a camel breathe on you,
boy.
Well, the reason we don't have receding
gums and livestock is because we've
dealt with the osteoporosis problem.
Receding gums is not a deficiency of
flossing. It's in fact osteoporosis of
the jawbones and of the facial bones. So
if you have gingivitis or receding gums,
you have advanced osteoporosis. Those
bones around your teeth are melting away
little bit by little bit every day. And
if you take your teeth out at night and
put them in a glass next to your bed and
that fizzy stuff, you have major
advanced osteoporosis because all your
bone has melted away. Okay. Then there's
arthritis.
We talked about that a little bit
earlier. Remember the chicken cartilage
or the nox gelatin. 85% of all arthritis
is caused by osteoporosis of the joint
ends of the bones. You're talking about
degenerative arthritis, osteoarthritis,
sciatica, lumbago, rheumatism, all those
sorts of things. Um, they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones. I want you to think about
something for a minute. If you don't
take a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis,
let's say you get arthritis of the hips,
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit, aren't you? You're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches.
You're going to favor it. And so, you
don't put any weight on it. I want you
to think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway. Either one, doesn't matter.
Whichever you love more. And um let's
say you didn't put the nut on that oil
pan real tight and all the oil drained
out. And that light on the dashboard
comes on says, "I'm getting hot. You
better give me some oil." And that light
irritates you. So you stop, you open up
the hood, you get your clippers out, you
know, your fence clippers, and you clip
the the wire to that light, you close
the hood, and you just keep driving.
Would you do that to your tractor or
your Mercedes? No, you wouldn't. But we
take those pain relievers for arthritis
and we go out there and square dance and
do the Texas stew step and do our five
mile walks and our aerobics. That pill
works real good, doc, because it killed
my pain and you're just wearing that
thing off faster and faster.
Then your doctor's really going to get
rich because you need joint replacement
surgery.
Then there's hypertension. This is one
of my favorites. So I'll put a star over
here.
Hypertension is high blood pressure.
What's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure? Give up salt. Everybody knows
that one. That's been ingrained in our
head. Well, they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock? It's
about that big. A salt block. No farmer
is going to be economically viable if
you don't put a salt block out for your
livestock. They're going to die. Kind of
your veterary bills are going to go
crazy. But we're supposed to believe
that we don't need salt. you can get
everything you need out of your lettuce
and your whole wheat bread and stuff
like that. Well, don't believe that one
either. If you believe that, I got some
more oceanfront property in Montana for
you. Remember those long live people put
a big chunk of rock salt the size of a
big black Concord grape in every cup of
tea and they drink about 40 cups of tea
a day because they live at high
altitudes where it's very dry. They have
to keep hydrated. And they put butter in
their tea. They put two ps of butter and
a chunk of rock salt. They don't put the
pink stuff or the blue stuff or skim
milk or what does he call it? Uh creora
or whatever it is. Okay, guess guess
what? The doctors who live to be 58 tell
you no salt, no butter. The people who
live to be 120, they put in butter and
salt. So, you got to make some choices.
Well, they took $30 million of your tax
money and two years ago after a 20-year
study, they came out and said that they
took 5,000 people with high blood
pressure. They took them off their
medication and put them on a reduced
salt diet, a restricted salt diet, and
they all died. No big surprise, but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy, right? But when they looked
at this results, they said that, oh,
only 99.7% of the people didn't get any
results from that before they died. 0.3%
did get some result, dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt. So, the referees
who judged that article said, "Oh,
doesn't matter. You might as well let
high blood pressure patients eat salted
peanuts and dill pickles and salt their
food to taste because it doesn't matter.
In fact, worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt. Then they
had a control group with 5,000 people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just by doubling
their calcium intake. Now, they didn't
cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication, but what they did
was they went to the doctor and he says,
"You don't need this medication anymore.
What are you doing?" Well, I'm on this
experiment where I double my calcium
intake. Anybody get a recall notice from
your doctor saying it's okay to salt
your food to taste and please do double
your calcium intake. Anybody get that?
Not a single one. That's very
interesting. Then, of course, there's
insomnia. That's where you roll around
all night and you get your you wake up
in the morning, you're more tired when
you went to bed. That's insomnia. Of
course, doctors have two treatments for
that. They have Hion, which is a
sleeping pill, and they have
barbbituates. They kill about 10,000
people a year with overdoses of those
things, but that's okay. It's a
prescription, and they're watching out
for us. And remember
uh George Bush when he went to Japan,
they gave him some Helion so he could
sleep on the way to Japan because of the
time difference. And when he woke up,
one of the the side effects of Hion is
nausea and vomiting.
I don't know how you say it in Japanese,
but it was very dramatic on world TV,
right? Not very presidential.
And so I'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador.
And then of course there's kidney
stones.
And then there's bone spurs, heel spurs,
and calcium deposits. Again, physicians
will tell you the first thing to give up
nutritionally is calcium and dairy
because they have this foolish belief,
the stupid belief, the ignorant belief
that the calcium in kidney stones, bone
spurs, heel spurs, and calcium deposits
come from uh your diet when instead it
only comes from your bones when you have
a raging osteoporosis. And when you get
these things, you need more calcium, not
less. Then there's cramps and twitches.
You wake up in the middle of the night
and your foot is all cramped up around
your neck and you say, "Lord, take me
from the knee down. I'm not going to
make it till morning." We've all
experienced that. That's very common.
Then there's PMS, premenstrual syndrome.
You know, the emotional and physical
stuff. The medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy. It's been shortened to
hysterctomy. That's a hundred-year-old
treatment. The doctors do about 285,000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year.
But it makes Mercedes payments, so they
do them. Even the AMA said they're
unnecessary, but they don't take their
licenses away. And people keep going to
them. You imagine a poor woman in her
30s. She says, "Doc, you got to do
something. Every time I go out to hang
up the clothes, my neighbor's kids run
down the basement screaming witch. My
own kids think I'm crazy. My husband's
leaving me. I'm going to lose my job.
You got to do something." Well, the
University of California, San Diego came
out three years ago now and said, "If
you just double the RDA of calcium
intake to get rid of 85% of the
emotional and physical symptoms of PMS."
And when that came out, there were huge
lines around the health food stores
around the blocks. And people had
sleeping bags cuz they closed before
they all got their calcium. And every
person in line was a man.
They were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that.
Okay. And lastly is low back pain. 85%
of Americans get low back pain. Whether
you work on a computer or you unload hay
or you drive big trucks, doesn't matter.
Low back is a big problem. Low back is
just osteoporosis of the vertebrae.
Whether you have a disc problem or
whatnot because if your disc doesn't
have anything to hold on to, your
vertebrae have melted away. What's going
to happen to the disc? Especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers. They go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them. Well, I just want you to look
at this quickly before we do the last
mineral. Low back. You go to an
arthopedic surgeon or rheatologist. You
might get a muscle relaxant. You might
get Valium and a muscle relaxant. You
get a laminctomy. You get your vertebrae
fuse. You might get a disc operation.
They don't tell you. 75% of the time
you'll never be the same again. Right.
PMS, you go to your OBGYn.
You can um go to an internist. You can
go to a family counselor, a shrink or
divorce attorney. Cramps and twitches,
you go to a neurologist. You go to a
sports medicine doctor, an internist.
Bone spurs, heel spurs, calcium
deposits, you go to a rheatologist, an
orthopedic surgeon or podiatrist. Kidney
stones, you go to a urologist or an
internist or a surgeon. Insomnia, you go
to a shrinker, a um sleep clinic or an
internist. hypertension, you go to a
cardiologist, an internist or a surgeon,
arthritis, a rheatologist, a orthopedic
surgeon or an internist. Receding gums,
you go to a dentist or a perodontist.
Osteoporosis, you go to all those health
specialists, including a Tum salesman
for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency. It cost you 10 cents a day
to deal with. Now, on the average,
because Americans have insurance and we
have Medicare and Medicaid, we spend on
the average $25,000 to $250,000.
And we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a calcium
deficiency. And we beg the doctors to do
it. We beg the doctors to do it. Well,
it's our choice. The last one I'll share
with you is diabetes. Everybody's
touched by diabetes. It's the number
three cause of death in adults in the
United States. Number three cause of
death. And it has terrible complications
and side effects. Diabetes. The side
effects include blindness of many kinds.
Then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant. There's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds. And
of course that contributes the number
one cause of death, which is the number
one cause of death. Uh then there is
amputations. Everybody ought to have one
of those because they're totally paid
for in their health thing because they
assume that you're not just going to get
one because you want to get everything
on your health benefits. And then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average, you have a
shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes. Now, we learned
in 1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals. That's a pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals. in
1957 in animals. It was published in
Federation Proceedings, which is the
official journal of the American
Science, the National Institutes of
Health, the official monthly journal. It
was August 1957.
Well, the two trace minerals that you
can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and venadium. Venadium alone,
according to the University of
Vancouver, British Columbia Medical
School, venadium alone will replace
insulin
in adult onset diabetics, which
represent 85% of all diabetics. Of
course, they can't quit their insulin
cold turkey. They got to gradually wean
off of it. Takes four to 6 months for
most people to slowly wean off of
insulin if they're taking in adequate
amounts of chromium and venadium. I've
seen it work on hundreds and hundreds of
people. Now, to me, this is criminal
because if you write to uh Hills packing
company that makes Science Dot dog food
right over here in Topeka, Kansas. I
don't know if I'm pointing west, but
that way, okay, they're all saying that
way.
Topeka, Kansas. They manufacture science
diet dog food and other science diet
product, high-tech foods for animals. If
you write them and say, "How many
minerals exactly is in science diet for
dog food?" They'll write you back and
say, "There's 40 minerals." You write
checkerboard square in St. Louis,
Rosian, and say, "Just how many minerals
are in your rat pellets for laboratory
rats?" And they'll say, "There's 28
minerals."
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new $100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula in a grocery store that
has more than 11. So, our dogs get 40
minerals. Remember, that's what Mike
Murphy was saying. His dog never seems
to get sick because he's getting this
canned dog food with all these vitamins
and minerals in there. So our dogs get
40 minerals, our rats get 28 minerals,
and our human infants get 11. Is that
fair? No. That's called fraud.
Doesn't matter if you're talking about
SMA, Similac, Ismill, Pro Soyb. In fact,
that's why they call Simolac Simileac
because it lacks everything.
Okay? If I've convinced you that you
have to consciously take in all the
minerals yourself, that you can't depend
on your food, and certainly you can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled. There's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about. One is metallic
minerals, and metallic minerals are
essentially ground up rocks. Metallic
minerals are things like oyster shell,
eggshell, dolomite, limestone, uh
calcium carbonate, clays of various
kinds, Mount Maruanite clay, seabed
minerals. They're
only 8 to 12% absorbable. When you reach
age 35 to 40, it drops down to 3 to 5%.
And I have to tell you a story here.
Some of you heard this on the show
today. I ran into a guy at a meeting
like this up at Grand Rapids, Michigan.
And this fellow owns a porta potty
business. You know that's that green or
blue colored outouse. Man, if we'd only
had one of those back when I was a kid.
We had these ones with splinters, you
know, in the the wood. Any rate, um, he
said, "I see some something that that
describes that in my portaotty
business." I said, "What's that?" He
says, "Well, we take those things back
to the shop to clean them out with a
pressure hose." He says, "We put a
quarterinch grid underneath them because
kids throw rocks and sticks and toys in
there, and if we don't put a grid there,
it blocks up the sewer system. It cost
us thousands of dollars to fix it." He
says, "Every time we clean one of those
out, we find hundreds of vitamin
tablets." I said, "Well, how do you know
they're vitamin tablets?" He says,
"Well, it's really easy." He says,
"Right on the coating, it says the gramm
one a day sent."
He says, "Come here." He takes me out in
the back of his shop and there's this
literal mountain of all these vitamin
pills he got out of his portaotties.
That's because you can't absorb metallic
minerals. If you read the labels on
those multiples, they say your iron
comes in the form of iron oxide.
What is iron oxide? Rust.
You might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement. Well, that's what
they're giving you. Well, uh, show you
how bad it is. If you take something
like calcium lactate, which which is a
common metallic mineral, uh, let's say
it's a calcium table of calcium lactate,
1,000 milligrams. If you take two of
those, you're not getting 2,000
milligrams of calcium. In fact, I have
people all the time say, "Well, I took
lots of calcium, doc. I hear you on the
radio talking about calcium and
arthritis, and I took 2,000 milligrams
of calcium a day. Didn't help my
arthritis. In fact, it got worse." I
said, "What kind of calcium you taking?"
They said, "Calcium lactate." Well,
there's your problem because only 250 mg
of that is metallic calcium. So, let's
say you absorb 10% of that. Then the
other 750 mg is lactose or milk sugar.
So, 10% of 250 is 25. So, if you take
two of those tablets, you're not getting
2,000, you're getting 50 milligrams.
So, to get what you need, you need to
take 90 of those tablets a day. You need
to take 30 with each meal. And you got
59 more minerals to go.
And there's those people who want to do
things naturally. Let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 pounds of
spinach. And let's be fair. Let's see if
you can get 1,000 milligrams of
magnesium. I pick magnesium because in
green leafy vegetables, you have a lot
of magnesium because of the chlorophyll,
right? It's part of the chlorophyll
molecule. And any pound of anything, you
got 454 grams. In 10 pounds of spinach,
you got 4540 grams of which most of that
97% is water. And let's say you have one
gram of chlorophyll in that 10 lbs of
spinach. There's 50 milligrams of
magnesium. You got to divide that into
the thousand you want. You get a factor
of 20, which you multiply times the 10.
You have to eat 200 lb of spinach. You
got 58 more minerals to go. Okay? So,
you got to be a pretty big person to
accomplish all this. Even as big as I
am, you can't get it done. So, I prefer
to supplement rather than do those
things. Then of course during the 60s
the agricultural industry came up with
chelated minerals. Chelated minerals
because farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar of something that goes
into an animal's mouth and have 99 cents
come out in the manure. So I have to
really thank farmers for being that
clever. And chelated minerals are just
metallic minerals with an amino acid or
protein or enzyme wrapped around the
metal atom and increase the
absorbability to 40%. Then the health
food industry jumped on that right away
because it was a major improvement in
absorbability of minerals. The most
efficient way to absorb minerals is the
colloidal farm. Colloidal minerals are
98% absorbable. Two and a half times
more available than chelated minerals
and 10 times more available than
metallic minerals. And they're very
interesting. They're liquid. They can
only be liquid. Can't be pills, powders,
or uh capsules. They're very small
particle size are 7,000 times smaller
than a red blood cell and they're
negatively charged. Every particle is
negatively charged. Your intestinal
lining is positively charged. So you
actually have an electrical or magnetic
gradient that concentrates these
minerals around the lining of your
intestine. These three things together
give you the 98% absorbability. Now
plants have a very interesting part to
play in colloidal minerals. Remember we
said that plants cannot create minerals.
If they're not in the soil, plants can't
make them. Remember that US Senate
document 264 says they're not in the
soil anymore. At any rate, metallic
minerals are taken up by plants when
they're in the soil. Plants convert them
in their tissues to colloidal minerals.
And this is how we store minerals in our
body. This is how we use minerals in our
body. This is how we transport minerals
from their storage place to their site
of use in the colloidal form. Well, our
plants, our crops don't have much in the
way of colloidal minerals in them
because we don't have any metallic
minerals in our soil. Is this important?
Well, yeah. These long live cultures who
live to be 120 to 140, they have certain
common denominators. They all live in
high mountain villages that are above
8,500 to 14,000 ft in elevation. They
all have less than 2 in of precipitation
a year. They don't have any rain. They
don't have any snow. They don't have any
dew. Okay? They have very very dry
places. And guess what? They get all
their drinking water and all their
irrigation water for their crops from
what we call glacial milk. Glaciers in
every one of those communities grind up
the parent rock of those mountains about
4 in a year. There's more than 60 to 72
minerals in each one of those places.
The water that comes out from underneath
those glaciers is not clear like
Perriier or Evian water or Poland water
or geyser water. You take a glass full
of it up and hold it up. It looks like
Jersey milk. I mean it is either yellow,
white or white blue. It looks like milk
and it's called in titty kaka. See I got
to say it again in titty kaka or Tibet.
They all call it glacial milk cuz it
looks like milk. And not only have they
consumed it, drunk it and got 8 to 12%
until they were 35 to 40 and then 3 to
5% absorption for 2500 to 5,000 years
depending on the culture. More
importantly, they have irrigated with it
year after year, crop after crop,
generation after generation for 2500 to
5,000 years. They have no diabetes. They
have no heart disease, no high blood
pressure, no arthritis, no osteoporosis,
no cancer, no cataracts, no glaucoma.
They have no birth defects.
They have no jails full of drug addicts.
They have no taxes. They have no
doctors. Yet they live to be 120 to 140
without disease. Are these colloidal
minerals important? You bet your life
they're important. And every time you
don't take them in every day, you're
chopping off a few hours or a few days
of your life. Okay. Now, most people are
not going to go to Hanza or Tibet or
Tittykaka
because we don't have Kenmore kitchens
there or even Saturn cars or TV
changers, channel changers or
electricity. They don't have insulated
houses. They don't have central heating
or air conditioning, but what they do
have is colloidal minerals.
This is Dr. Wallik with a final message.
Information gives you the ability to
make decisions with confidence. I hope
you've enjoyed my message. By giving
your body the proper raw materials every
day, you'll be taking the necessary
steps in living healthier and living
longer. Make the decision to take
control of your personal health and
longevity program today. Colloidal
minerals are not like antibiotics. You
don't get a prescription which you use
for 10 days and then you're done. Your
prescription for colloidal minerals
should only expire when your need for
oxygen expires. You need to supplement
your diet with the 90 essential
nutrients each and every day of your
life. Millions of people have heard my
message all across the world and have
now decided to make the consumption of
colloidal minerals a daily ritual. Just
as there are many manufacturers of
aspirin, there are now many
manufacturers of vitamins and mineral
supplements. Be sure to get your liquid
colloidal minerals derived only from the
very best organic plant source deposits.
Colloidal minerals are the mineral
source our bodies were designed to use,
not ground up rocks. Since you will most
likely be supplementing your diet each
and every day, don't get caught paying
retail prices. My daddy always said,
"Why pay retail when you can buy
wholesale?" One of my trusted colleagues
will show you how to purchase the
highest quality products wholesale so
you can save gobs of money off the
retail price